real hope is scarred
real hope is wounded real hope has had
to be resurrected more than once in
America right now there are kids
considering suicide as we're having this
because this world has made them feel
lesser than because of who they are
there are people hurting with at a
kitchen table so they don't know how the
economics are going to work there is
real pain and hurt and the answer isn't
to Buck up and be positive the answer is
to confront it to find a way to connect
and let people know that you're not
alone that we're all broken we all effed
up multiple times but as broken as we
are ultimately
those cracks and those Jagged edges we
all have perhaps make it better to fit
together with other people who are just
as broken and fractured to create a
stronger whole and a better bond that
gives that gives hope